so you unveiled the slew of new products
today you're redesigning the desktop
product you're improving the feed you're
adding in BOTS how do you expect these
things to fit into the roadmap of
increasing user engagement ahead of this
acquisition
yeah well feeds you know helping our
members to stay connected and informed
is one of our central value propositions
and that's really at the foundation of
our flagship application both mobile and
as you mentioned today we're gonna be
redesigning the desktop as well so
continue to invest very aggressively and
create the most relevant newsfeed
possible within a professional context
messaging makes it much easier for
people to keep in touch with their
network for people to reach out to the
people they want to be doing business
with and that overhaul relative to the
the prior inbox we've seen very material
lifts so over two hundred and forty
percent year-over-year growth there so
these things all kind of compound to
lift engagement now I know we're waiting
for the acquisition to close but you
said on stage you've been rolling up
your sleeves digging in with the team
let us in on what it's like to plan for
an integration like this yeah there's a
lot of clarity in terms of the value
that can be generated by virtue of
leveraging LinkedIn is unique assets
identity assets connection assets some
of our business applications and to
integrate that as seamlessly as possible
on top of Microsoft's footprint of north
of a billion users you know it's one of
only a handful of technology companies
that reach a billion plus users on a
global basis so we've been working with
teams the outlook team for example the
windows team the office team the
dynamics team to think about what's
possible and prepare so that once we
close we can hit the ground with our
feet running what integrations should we
expect to see first yeah so first I
wouldn't be predicting first in terms of
chronological order but some of the
areas that we think make absolute sense
integrating LinkedIn identity assets
within outlook for example outlook.com
so that when someone sends you an email
you know who they are
if you're less familiar with them you're
able to add them to your network that
makes sense if you're already familiar
with them you see if they change the job
changed company what they've shared
recently so it really brings the inbox
to life in that regard there's some
really interesting stuff we can do with
regard to Windows integration in terms
of the activity center and
Asians we'd love to more deeply
integrate some of our learning assets
into Windows into office and then
dynamics with regard to continuing to
differentiate some of the business
applications that are generating real
momentum on Microsoft through leveraging
sales navigator things we can do with
recruiter in terms of human capital
management so those are some of the
areas of focus now I understand the idea
is for LinkedIn to remain largely
independent Reid Hoffman told me sort of
like Facebook and Instagram how do you
expect this to work in practice and how
do you think it will impact the culture
of LinkedIn that you've worked very hard
to build yeah from day one Satya said
it's really important that we continue
to focus on growing LinkedIn on
realizing our mission and accelerating
the realization of our mission and
vision and both teams are completely
aligned behind that objective so that
makes it a lot easier it's also made
easier by the fact that to your point
about culture you know that's oftentimes
where a lot of M&A goes off the rails
you have two disparate cultures
misaligned and in this particular case
the underlying cultures are both company
already naturally aligned in terms of
being mission driven no Satya has been
very mission and purpose driven since
he's taken on the role of CEO in terms
of being innovative in terms of trying
to create a sense of openness and the
speed and agility required to make that
stuff happen so along those lines we're
seeing a lot of alignment